good morning Hank it's Wednesday and
this is the beginning of my zombie
apocalypse novella presump efficacious
my father was already obsessed with corn
he told me almost every day that corn
was in control of us corn wants the
world to contain more corn so corn
evolves us to agree with it corn tells
us that we could make sugar out of corn
or fuel out of corn or plastic out of
corn the flu makes us cough which
spreads the flu corn makes us corn
hungry which spreads corn he got this
idea from a book and he never ceased to
be amazed by it for years he would come
back to it would be eating mashed
potatoes or something and he'd say you
know potatoes are impossible without
corn that corn it's everywhere he meant
that metaphorically although it is now
nearly true literally I think my dad was
so fascinated by this idea because he
realized on some fundamental level that
he was not in control of his own desires
I think he woke up every morning in his
nice house with hardwood floors and
granite countertops and wondered why he
desired granite countertops and hardwood
floors in the first place
wondered who exactly was running the
show most people never stopped to wonder
why they liked pop-tarts or bran flow
shower heads or skinny girls or whatever
it is they liked although he never
abandoned his narrowly circumscribed
suburban life the why of it always
nagged my dad I inherited that penchant
for intellectual curiosity a character
flaw that these days can only be
thoroughly eradicated by getting Zeid up
anyway I've been thinking about the old
man lately because it was a year ago
today that I shot him in the chest with
a hollow-point 45 caliber bullet he kind
of smiled as he fell backwards onto the
overstuffed livingroom couch he took a
minute to die and it was the smiling
ggest minute i'd ever seen out of him a
lot of those eat up smile when you kill
them I don't know if they're grateful or
amused or what but it helps with the
guilt which quite a lot of people feel I
knew a kid once who was the kind of
sentimentalist who found it troubling to
think of himself as a murderer so he
called killing zzz completing them i
like that
that kid his name was Marcos Marcos he
got Z double we were living in a very
nice heavily chandelier Lincoln Park
townhouse with a few other humanoid
types and then one morning Marcos Marcos
made a go at my pub
mr. president and I had to complete him
I completed his head all over the dining
room credenza of that fancy townhouse
and then me and mr. president bolted out
for the proverbial higher ground newsies
always go for dogs and cats and cows
first because they've still got enough
of a moral compass to recognize that
separating human beings from their vital
organs aside from being ethically
troubling is cannibalistic it is my own
moral compass that has done me and now
working through the last few gallons of
the gas that runs the generator that
pumps the putrid Zeit out air down here
eating through the last rusted cans of
diced tomatoes and spam drinking very
expensive red wine at the rate of
precisely one bottle per day watching
the shelves empty out wondering as my
father did what terrible monster working
inside of me forces me to go on rowing
against the current when I could just
walk up a staircase unlock this cellar
door and get Zeid up like a normal
person
so weak that's the first page of my
zombie apocalypse novella which will
never be published not because I dislike
zombie apocalypse novellas but because
mine is bad that's by far the best page
of it gets much worse from there however
the only copy of my zombie apocalypse
novella that will ever exist will be
just one of many amazing project for
awesome raffle prizes
speaking of which nerdfighters I hope
you're hard at work on your project for
awesome videos if you want to know more
about what the project for awesome is
look in my pants
Hank I don't want to give too much away
but on December 17th and 18th project
for awesome videos are going to be
featured all over YouTube so
nerdfighters make those project for
awesome videos awesome dftba like it
says on my shirt Hank I'll see you on
Friday